hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to show you how to do liver
flushing now what is liver flushing
we're not going to be using olive oil or
magnesium salts or beets we're going to
do it manually with acupressure okay so
check this out
so the liver is right here it's the size
of a football okay and the ribcage comes
around right underneath here and so what
we want to do is you want to gently
press up underneath that rib cage like
right here just my thumbs just to make
sure there's no not to - tenderness and
we're just holding this pressure for
like a minute okay and then we ease up
more down this way pressing into the
liver right here we're just holding this
pressure we're basically taking the
liver as an organ and getting it to
drain properly through the little ducks
it's called the bile ducts okay because
a lot of times the liver is congested so
we're going to just call the liver flush
we're just going to press in here can
kind of ease on down here spend like
like a minute right here here in here
I'm just going to press on that's that
spot there a lot of people have
congestion in this area because the
gallbladder and the liver is all just
jammed up so this allows everything to
drain properly and it will feel a lot
better but now I'm going to show you how
to do it so you're going to take your
thumb and you can take your other thumb
and you can press into this spot up
there but you want to come kind of come
up underneath at an angle in this way
yeah
perfect okay so you feel that there so
you can feel a little soreness right
ticklish okay yeah well it's better you
tickling yourself to me right so as
she's holding that pressure you know
we're just holding it gently we're not
pressing too hard and everything is kind
of draining through and then we'll
slowly after about a minute we'll come
right here okay and you press right
there and then you press right here okay
and you just hold that pressure now
if you have a massage tool this is a
tool that I have you can hold to a lot
of my clients have this tool and it
allows different sized devices to press
into you can feel that there right so
that way you don't have to strain your
hands and you could work on holding this
pressure and you can see this we just
tilt it this way this is going right in
there just gently and that the way I
like this one is that your your doing it
no one else is doing it you can adjust
the pressure you can go light and just
hold it there for a period of time of
course don't do this with a like a
machete or a knife okay so now we're
going to lower it right here we come
down there we just hold that pressure do
that for two minutes and you can go
right here now a lot of times people
want to know what about if I have my
gallbladder removed okay what do I do
well if it's sore if it's too sore to
press right there because you have an
incision in your trauma the cool thing
to do is you can work on the opposite
side the pancreas and the pancreas
actually is works together with the
gallbladder which is right here to help
digestion so you would work on the
pancreas because if you don't have a
gallbladder guess what your pancreas is
working really hard to produce the
enzyme to digest so you're going to have
to work on the pancreas if you don't
have a gallbladder work on the opposite
side okay
now you might find that this is sore no
it tickles the muscles kind of muscle
jumping yeah okay so then we'd work on
this side we work a little lower here do
the same exact thing on the left side
and you could even do both sides just to
make sure because you know it doesn't
hurt to kind of get your digestive
organs kind of work down I mean think
about it you work on the muscles you to
massage but who works on the organs
right it's kind of like visceral massage
and we're working on the organs getting
in
getting them to drain properly because
it's just a lot of people have let
attention if there's problems through
either side a lot of times you have a
stiff neck because the nerves go right
up and through up into the neck it's
called a phrenic nerve you got the vagus
nerves they go rub into the neck of the
neck will be stiff and you work this out
your neck feels real nice and relaxed
okay
great so you can try this at home and
put your comments below